that's what the sound is when the joke
goes over your head welcome everybody
today we're going to review some people
that just don't get it
sometimes humour can just be too
intelligent for people to understand is
probably especially you my fellow 9 year
olds guessing what people say so what's
your talent it's kind of mixed a bit I
think the middle part should be here
hunt ha ha yes I feel like it's my
favorite thing to be ironically this guy
but you know it's not ironic which is
what makes it so good you can you can
taste how stupid years it's wonderful
910 redditors are effing morons I'm glad
to be the 1% one out of 10 it's 10%
that's it
the joke went right over your head
didn't it well done I feel like this is
my comments a lot of the times I gotta
say why does everyone type are whoosh
whenever I correct their stupidity with
all the recent true as success as
Trump's has had lately this is what
liberal is now complaining about the
joke here is of course that there hasn't
been enough Shrek films during the trump
administration this to me is not a joke
this is not a whoosh this is a whoosh
why am i uploading videos yeah I mean a
gang guys that go to school hmm I don't
think they quite know what an acronym is
you see I am 2008 IQ intellect points
I know exactly what an acronym is stupid
sonic fames
not being intellectual like me leg day
is the best day what legs that's funny
because I won the powerlifting squad
competition two years in a row the
second 24 year old to ever squat over
500 so I'm not really sure what your
meaning my legs aren't 18 inches around
I think you realize I think you watch me
when I do not see this giant small legs
they so big they so large your insults
doesn't work on me I was making a camo
joke oh the good old camo joke it's too
funny any time any I wear camo and
someone makes a camo joke is like oh no
this is gonna be kid found dead this
morning
r.i.p Steve Jobs to see you of Google
that's not him are you telling me that's
not Steve Jobs the CEO of Google quoted
from Bob Marley watch this is basically
your comments I just realize I'm reading
my own comments here do your brows you
read it and why no I have never been on
reddit might try it out one day but you
just reply to me already
oh it's another acronym yes I feed
return my library books this isn't even
an acronym that's a joke come right
thank you for making me explain the joke
well done
512 gigabyte ram yes now I can finally
open three tabs in Chrome I can I can
open over 100 tabs with 16 gigabyte LC
Bram oh well well done well you can't
understand a simple joke though
congratulation from you got pushed
I feel like a car needs to hit these
people as fast as the joke goes over
their head
gazing serious removed each was removed
what was it holy Africa by Toto was so
popular they named an entire continent
after it excuse me they named a 36
year-old son after a 7.5 million
year-old continent named some few
millennium ago nice one this is annoying
I'm just annoyed by these the problem
with quotes found on the Internet is
that they are often not true Abraham
Lincoln well this could be a quote from
him there was no internet back there Ben
when wills head himself finally show up
to the talk the final bus you guys know
TED talk stands for Technology
Entertainment and design talks right I
will not let Ted idea any longer say
what you want
oh by World War two but whoever killed
Hitler is my hero a true inspiration but
he killed himself maybe you should stick
Jesus Christ I don't understand how
anyone can joke about something like
this okay
this is the kind of like I see this a
lot recently memes memes people I don't
know if people are just dumb or if
they're purposely choosing to mean the
meme because you can't meme a meme the
meme is a meme itself the meme here is
that Thanos came from for at night but
this guy is trying to meme at the
opposite you can't steal a meme to me me
it annoys me stop it running was
invented in 1748 by Thomas running you
guys heard about this we heard about
Thomas running when he tried to walk
twice I'd say running is in our DNA
ok nobody invented it ok came and ran to
and from pray what's next John Smith
invented chewing get that BS added I
can't tell that people are you know
willfully ignorant that people are
memeing because they want so desperately
to be there haha got you now guy you
know what I mean why are so many people
dumb I feel really smart going through
this suburb Muslims in the USA removed
did anyone see the joke before it got
deleted full here me and intellectual
this guy is clearly memeing as well
right there's no whoosh here this is a
whoosh ception everybody well done
shower thoughts walking three miles per
hour it's calming and enjoyable but
driving 3 miles per hour
that's just aggravating and painful
excuse me
driving 30 miles per hour it's calming
and enjoyable but walking 30 miles per
hour is aggravating and painful as well
yeah
but walking at 30 miles per hour
is not possible you know what just went
past you 30 miles per hour push the joke
that's right everybody you idiot you
dummy you dumb ball dumb bang dumb the
schmuck
dumb me bump D bump bump you bump binary
and non-binary are both have asked I
don't even know why I waste my time
doing that people struggle with it so
it's not half as as your transphobic
post is trying to imply this post was
about programming
sometimes I just remember the fact that
in French pen or pain means bread and it
makes me think about this picture a lie
anyone else see the sad face though huh
anyone spotted the sad face haha you're
right I should have made a joke about
that what a perfect opportunity just
missed Thank You little baby dare huh I
can't believe he didn't notice the face
before poaching it I think it was such
sarcasm I think that was sarcasm too
this may be some sort of war ception
whoosh whooshing sure is fun I'm having
a blast whooshing people felis you got a
$5 to spend on the perfect girl 300
attract 150 cute $2 looks like the Luigi
$3 acts like why Luigi hundred dollars
loyal except for girls are living
breathing things that you can't buy not
to mention we're all beautiful
regardless of our variations in our
personalities and appearances well as
let me listen we're not being misogynist
here as long as you look like while
Luigi I'm all aboard
that makes me an IQ test before you get
to go on ready oh my god that was the
most reddit thing I've ever said
petition to hire 1 million people to put
their fingers in the shoot hole of
people's guns so they can't shoot them
it's still going to shoot no the finger
box the bullet we can do this this is a
gun we're talking about the projectile
is fired using explosion not by
compressed air open toy gun the finger
blocks it their finger won't block it
the shaft is only there to keep the
bullets straight no the bullet will go
forward a little it's really not that
hard to understand basic physics go back
to school Doh Mozilla adults your bunger
I am signing this petition right now who
would win a stick vs. 1000 US Marines
tough choice all it is is one marine to
break the stick
seriously what the f then you have two
sticks stick win every time you hear the
one about the airplane no yeah it
probably go over your head
I'm pretty smart try me
thank you guys for watching another
episode of woosh this is the first one
out of this is it this is literally it
if any of these jokes went over your
head vaga news for you
you have to leave a like on this video
right now to make the Edgar